imagine you are a mother and you have
just left an abusive relationship but
you've got a good job and all you need
to do is move you and your daughter into
an apartment you can pay the down
payment you can pay the last month's
rent you can see that I'm getting
regularly paid and there's more than
enough in the account but they were like
if you don't have a credit score you we
can't really look at you she was
categorically denied the ability to even
apply for some of the apartment
buildings Fred wey is a sociologist at
Princeton and that story came from a
woman he interviewed in San Francisco
back in 2017 today there are an
estimated 45 million Americans who don't
have a credit score and that can make it
really difficult to rent an apartment or
get car insurance or even get a job when
credit scores were invented just a few
decades ago they were hailed as a way to
democratize lending Play Down human
judgment and let computers make most of
the decisions in the United States today
credit scores have become essential not
having one can basically lock you out of
daily life and having a low score can
make life difficult too so how did we
get here what exactly are credit scores
and why do they keep so many people from
accessing what they
[Music]
need a credit score starts with a credit
report a record of some personal data
points about us like our ZIP code and
employment history plus our individual
history of paying our debt obligations
well some of our debt obligations see
only data supplied by big lending
institutions like Student Loan servicers
mortgage lenders credit card companies
and auto financers end up on our credit
reports we might be paying our cell
phone bills and our rent each month but
cell phone carriers and landlords don't
share that information with these guys
the credit reporting agencies there are
three and each one has its own version
of the credit history of more than 200
million people in the US that data comes
from institutions like credit card
companies and student loan providers who
send information about our accounts to
the credit reporting agencies the type
of loan the balance our payment history
and whether the loan has been sent to a
collection agency then credit scoring
companies like FICO and Vantage score
take that information and feed it into
an algorithm which calculates a score
between 300 and
850 the scoring companies are pulling
from the same three credit reports but
the scores don't always come out the
same one company's algorithm might put
more emphasis on the length of your
credit history the longer you've had
access to credit the higher your score
another company might put slightly more
emphasis on the mix of accounts the more
variety the higher the score other
factors include payment history ontime
payments mean higher scores for loans
like mortgages and student loans lower
account balances mean higher scores and
for credit card accounts the percentage
of my credit that I actually use the
lower that percentage The Better Credit
scoring companies make money the same
way that credit reporting companies do
by selling your score to landlords
lenders employers and others willing to
pay for it lenders use that information
to determine whether to loan US money
for a house a car or a college education
they also use that number to figure out
how much we should pay for that loan A
lender looks at a low credit score
decides I'm a risky borrower and charges
me a higher interest rate than my
neighbor with a higher score score and
this is where things get tricky for a
couple of reasons first there's a lot of
history baked into that credit score
that doesn't show up on a credit report
and second it's not just lenders who are
looking at this information and making
decisions that can affect my life we're
going to get into all that but first a
quick note from the people at secret
student loans can really make you sweat
only one in three students understand
the financial terms of their loans and
nearly half a federal student loan bar
borrowers don't know how much they owe
or who they owe it to so how can
borrowers go from confused to
confident it might sound obvious but
research shows a strong connection
between financial literacy and
successful student debt management so
let's build out a financial literacy
toolkit first thing to consider is the
numbers find out how much you owe and
what your interest rate is prioritize
paying off the loans with the highest
interest rate first second is to learn
the terminology this helps you
understand why what your options are for
example Auto deit is when you set up
automatic monthly payments which may
reduce your interest rate by 0.25% bonus
tip call your lender and see if you can
have your payments go directly towards
your principal which is the amount of
money you borrowed so you can pay off
your loans faster look into refinancing
that's combining loans into one with a
new lender potentially also getting a
lower interest rate find out if you
qualify for student loan forgiveness
that way you can have some or all of
your Federal loans lifted and the last
thing in the toolkit making the plan
follow through on the approach that
works for you maybe you qualify for the
save plan or maybe you can make even
higher monthly payments to prevent more
interest from
acre make a plan that fits within your
financial goals by understanding your
student loans you can take charge of
them learn more at secret.com money
moves so how did we get the credit
system that we have today well like a
lot of systems in the US we need to go
back and look at the past to understand
the present for most of American History
uh creditworthiness was really a
function of your personal character
whether the community and people who
were interacting with you believed you
to be a trustworthy honest Dependable
person my name is Josh laow I'm a
professor of media studies at the
University of New Hampshire and the
department of communication he's also
the author of this book creditworthy a
history of credit in the United States
in this interpersonal credit system a
dress maker in Boston might buy fabric
from a general store on credit which the
storekeeper bought from a local textile
mill on credit who bought the cotton
from his second cousin a planter in
Georgia on credit those lines of credit
were built on personal relationships the
thing is there was a lot of Labor
happening behind the scenes to make
those credit relationships possible from
the enslaved people whose labor created
the Planter's wealth to the literal
children working in the mill to the
unpaid or underpaid care work that made
the store owner and dressmaker business
as possible those people weren't part of
this credit system which has
ramifications for the system we have
today we'll get more into that later on
but this whole interpersonal credit
system it really starts to break down
after the Civil War and this is a period
where you have people who are moving
around you have new transportation
systems and so you have people who want
to have business relationships with
people in more farway places that
they've never met and they have no basis
for understanding what their reputation
is and most importantly whether or not
they could be trusted to repay a debt
that was given to them in the 1870s you
start to see these handwritten credit
reports this one is for RH Macy founder
of Macy's department store the business
is a lucrative one they pay everything
in 10 and 30 days and never owe much
reports like these were meant for other
merchants or lenders people who didn't
know Macy but were considering whether
to do business with him soon books like
this one let retailers share information
about their customers with each other
like whether PD Jones of Brooklyn paid
on time and should be offered credit by
the 1950s those reports looked like this
investigators working for the credit
bureaus indicated Race using the dubious
categories of the time as well as
character habits and morals according to
one training manual investigators
working for the credit bureaus were
instructed to uncover whether a borrower
was promiscuous and if so the extent of
Partners as well as possible
homosexuality both of which were
considered legitimate reasons to deny
someone access to credit there were many
women who couldn't get credit cards or
couldn't get open in a credit account
because the accounts are always in a
man's name and there were minorities who
could not get credit accounts because it
was a Rec's credit economy banks will
not lend money for a negro to purchase
in other than what is termed settled
areas those are areas where there is
already a negro population so these two
things ultimately lead to the equal
Credit Opportunity Act and that begins
to regulate the kinds of information
that can even be considered in credit
decisions but just because categories
like race gender and sexuality are no
longer officially included in credit
reports it doesn't mean that they can't
show up in other ways for example we
know that black workers are more likely
than white workers to be let go during a
recession so that means that employment
history can end up being a proxy for
race that does show up up on our credit
reports if you are more likely to be let
go in a downturn and be let go earlier
than your counterparts then you're going
to have an employment history that looks
as if you're not as stable if you are in
a neighborhood whose homes have not
appreciated at the same rate as people
in other neighborhoods that have nothing
to do with the quality of the home
whether or not you've been paying on the
home suddenly you just don't look as if
you were in a good a position as some
others for taking out certain types of
debt or being entrusted with certain
kinds of credit when my grandfather
returned home from the Korean War he got
a cheap federally backed mortgage that
was not available to the black soldiers
that he served with and when he died and
his kids sold the house part of that
money went to my dad who used it to get
a cheap mortgage and build a good credit
history and if you multiply that story
by Mill millions of families across the
country you can start to see how the
impact of racist policies can
reverberate for Generations after the
laws themselves have been repealed you
have an entire history of exclusion that
gets excluded in the moment that a a
history of credit is being assessed
today more than half of black adults
have a credit score below 650 which
means they're usually charged
significantly higher interest rates for
a 30-year mortgage than someone with a
higher score and credit scores don't
just lock people out of affordable
mortgages more than half of all
Employers in the US say that they
consult an applicant's credit history
when hiring so how can we fix the credit
system to account for these
disparities lawmakers in some cities and
states have started by outlawing the use
of credit scores to make decisions that
aren't about lending money like hiring
and promotions or car insurance people
without a credit history or with a low
score they might still be engaging in
creditworthy activities like taking part
in an informal lending Circle where
friends each contribute a set amount
each month and then every person gets
the full payout once one option might be
to empower local credit unions or
nonprofits to formalize these circles
and Report those payments to credit
monitoring agencies which could help
participants build good credit histories
a few startups are even trying to bypass
the traditional credit scoring system
altogether instead they're making loans
based on rent payment histories and
other data if you want your kids to go
to college and you don't come from
wealth then you're probably choosing to
engage in a credit system and to engage
in debt if I don't have my credit card
with me it's going to be hard to check
into a hotel it's going to be hard to
rent a car access to credit has really
become a necessary key for participating
in American life and the system we have
today reflects a history in which not
everyone had access to that key When I
Look to YouTube for solutions for this
problem a lot of the fixes are aimed at
individuals tips and tricks for boosting
your score and fixing your credit and
that stuff is helpful but if we're going
to level the playing field and give more
people a fair shot we're going to have
to think
bigger